dans cette sorte de science douce. »
Et il a commencé à me dire
que les rats, comme les humains,
lèchent leur bébé de manières différentes.
Certaines mères sont très attentionnées,
d'autres très peu
et la majorité sont au milieu.
Mais ce qui est intéressant,
c'est que quand il suit ces jeunes lorsqu'ils deviennent adultes,
l'équivalent de plusieurs années humaines, bien longtemps après la mort de la mère,
ce sont des animaux complètement différents.
Les animaux qui ont été fortement léchés et brossés,
les fortement léchés et brossés,
ne sont pas stressés.
Ils ont un comportement sexuel différent.
Ils ont une manière de vivre différente
de ceux dont la mère n'a pas pris autant soin.
Et donc, je me demandais :
est-ce de la magie ?
Comment ça marche ?
Un généticien aimerait vous faire croire
que la mère avait peut-être un gène de « mauvaise mère »
qui a rendu ses petits stressés
et qui a été transmis de génération en génération,
ça serait déterminé par la génétique.
Ou est-il possible que quelque chose d'autre se passe ?
Chez les rats, on peut tester cette question et y répondre.
Ce que l'on a fait est une expérience d'adoptions croisées.
Il suffit de séparer la portée, les bébés de cette rate, à la naissance,
donnés à deux types de mères adoptives,
pas leur vraie mère, mais des mères qui s'occuperont d'eux,
des mères attentionnées et des mères qui le sont moins.
Et on peut faire l'inverse avec des petits moins soignés.
Et la réponse étonnante était
que le gène reçu de la mère n'était pas important.
Ce n'était pas la mère biologique qui définissait le comportement des bébés,
c'était la mère qui les élèvait.
Comment cela peut-il marcher ?
Je suis un épigénéticien.
Je m'intéresse à la manière dont les gènes sont marqués
par des agents chimiques pendant l'embryogenèse,
lorsque nous sommes dans le ventre de notre mère,
et qui décident quels gènes seront exprimés
dans quel tissu.
Des gènes différents sont exprimés dans le cerveau, le foie ou l’œil.
Et on a pensé : est-il possible
que la mère reprogramme les gènes de sa progéniture
par son comportement ?
On y a passé dix ans
et on a découvert qu'il y a une cascade d’événements biochimiques
par lesquels le léchage et le brossage de la mère, son attention,
sont traduits en signaux biochimiques
qui vont dans le noyau et dans l'ADN
et le programment différemment.
Donc maintenant, l'animal peut se préparer à la vie.
Est-ce que la vie sera dure ?
Va-t-il y avoir beaucoup de nourriture ?
Y aura-t-il beaucoup de chats et de serpents aux alentours ?
Ou vivra-t-on dans un quartier bourgeois
où il faut simplement se comporter correctement
et cela permettra d'obtenir l'acceptation sociale ?
Nous pouvons nous rendre compte combien ce procédé peut être important
dans notre vie.
Nous héritons de notre ADN par nos ancêtres.
Cet ADN est vieux.
Il a évolué pendant l'évolution.
Mais il ne nous dit pas si nous allons naître à Stockholm,
où les jours sont longs en été et courts en hiver,
ou en Équateur,
où il y a autant d'heures pour le jour et la nuit toute l'année.
Et ça a un impact très important sur notre physiologie.
Ce que l'on suggère est que peut-être que ce qu'il se passe au début de la vie,
ces signaux qui viennent de la mère disent à l'enfant
dans quel type de monde social il vivra.
Est-ce que ce sera rude et il vaut mieux être anxieux et stressé ?
Ou est-ce que ce sera un monde facile où il faudra être différent ?
Est-ce que ce sera un monde avec beaucoup ou peu de lumière ?
Est-ce que ce sera un monde avec beaucoup ou peu de nourriture ?
S'il n'y a pas de nourriture,
le cerveau doit développer une attraction compulsive à la nourriture
ou stocker chaque repas ingéré sous forme de graisse.
C'est bien.
L'évolution a choisi cela
pour permettre à notre vieil ADN fixe de fonctionner dynamiquement
dans de nouveaux environnements.
Mais parfois, cela peut mal se passer.
Par exemple, si on naît dans une famille pauvre,
les signaux seront : « Tu devrais te goinfrer,
manger chaque morceau de nourriture que tu croises. »
Mais, nous les humains et notre cerveau avons évolué,
avons accéléré l'évolution.
On peut à présent acheter un [hamburger] à McDonald pour 1 dollar.
Et donc l'entraînement que nous avons eu de notre mère
devient inadapté.
Cette préparation qui devait nous protéger de la faim et de la famine
va causer l'obésité,
les problèmes cardiovasculaires et des maladies métaboliques.
Ce concept disant que les gènes seraient marqués par notre expérience,
en particulier celle du début de notre vie,
peut nous fournir une explication unifiée
sur la santé et la maladie.
Mais est-ce vrai seulement pour les rats ?
Le problème, c'est qu'on ne peut pas tester cela chez les humains,
à cause de l'éthique, on ne peut rendre une enfance éprouvante aléatoirement.
Donc, si un enfant pauvre développe certaines propriétés,
on ne sait pas si c'est causé par la pauvreté
ou par le fait que les gens pauvres ont de mauvais gènes.
Les généticiens essaieront de vous dire que les pauvres sont pauvres
parce que leurs gènes les ont rendus pauvres.
Les épigénéticiens vous diront
que les pauvres sont dans un environnement mauvais ou appauvri,
qui crée ce phénotype, cette propriété.
Nous avons donc observé nos cousins, les singes.
Mon collègue Stephen Suomi a élevé des singes
de deux manières.
Séparant aléatoirement le singe de sa mère
et l'élevant avec une nourrice
dans des conditions de mère de substitution.
Ces singes n'avaient pas de mère, ils avaient une nourrice.
Et les autres singes étaient élevés avec leur mère naturelle.
Et quand ils étaient plus vieux, c'étaient des animaux différents.
Les singes qui avaient une mère ne s'intéressaient pas à l'alcool,
ils n'étaient pas violents sexuellement.
Les singes sans mère étaient agressifs, stressés
et alcooliques.
On a regardé leur ADN après la naissance,
pour voir si la mère les marquait.
Y a-t-il une signature de la mère dans l'ADN des enfants ?
Ce sont des singes au jour 14
et ce que vous voyez ici est la manière moderne dont on étudie l'épigénétique.
On représente les marqueurs chimiques, appelés marqueurs de méthylation,
sur l'ADN, à l'échelle d'un nucléotide.
On peut représenter le génome entier.
On peut comparer le singe qui a eu une mère et celui qui n'en a pas eu.
Et en voici une présentation visuelle.
Vous voyez les gènes qui ont été plus méthylés en rouge.
Les gènes qui ont été moins méthylés sont verts.
Vous pouvez voir que beaucoup de gènes changent,
Parce que ne pas avoir de mère n'est pas un simple fait,
ça affecte l'ensemble.
Ça nous envoie des signaux sur ce à quoi va ressembler notre monde
quand nous devenons adulte.
Et vous pouvez voir que les deux groupes de singes
sont extrêmement bien séparés.
A partir de quel stade cela va-t-il se développer ?
Ces singes n'ont déjà pas vu leur mère
donc ils ont eu une expérience sociale.
Peut-on sentir notre statut social avant même de naître ?
Dans cette expérience, on a pris des placentas de singes
de statuts sociaux différents.
Ce qui est intéressant avec le statut social,
c'est que tous les êtres vivants vont se structurer selon une hiérarchie.
Le singe numéro un est le chef.
Le singe numéro quatre est l'ouvrier.
Et lorsque l'on met quatre singes en cage,
il y aura toujours un chef et un ouvrier.
Et, de manière intéressante, le singe numéro un
a une meilleure santé que le singe numéro quatre.
Et s'ils sont mis dans une cage,
le singe numéro un ne mangera pas beaucoup
et le singe numéro quatre mangera plus.
Ce que vous voyez ici sur cette carte de méthylation,
c'est une séparation dès la naissance
des animaux avec un haut niveau social,
opposés aux animaux qui n'ont pas un haut statut.
On naît donc en sachant déjà l'information sociale
et cette information n'est pas mauvaise ou bonne,
elle nous prépare juste à la vie,
car on doit programmer notre biologie différemment
selon que l'on a un statut social élevé ou non.
Mais comment peut-on étudier ça chez les humains ?
On ne peut pas faire d'expériences, on ne peut pas leur imposer une épreuve.
Mais Dieu fait des expériences sur nous,
ça s'appelle des catastrophes naturelles.
Une des plus dures catastrophes naturelles dans l'histoire du Canada
a eu lieu dans ma province, le Québec.
C'est la tempête de neige de 1998.
On a perdu notre réseau électrique entier à cause de cette tempête
quand les températures allaient, en plein cœur de l'hiver au Québec,
de -20 à -30°C.
Et il y avait des femmes enceintes à cette période.
Et ma collègue, Suzanne King, a suivi les enfants de ces mères
pendant 15 ans.
Et ce qu'il s'est passé, c'est qu'alors que le stress augmentait --
et nous avions une mesure objective du stress :
le temps passé sans électricité, où vous aviez passé ce temps,
si c'était dans l'appartement de votre belle-mère
ou dans une maison bourgeoise.
Tout cela s'additionnait en une échelle de stress social
et on s'est posé la question :
à quoi ressemblaient les enfants ?
Il est apparu qu'avec l'augmentation du stress,
les enfants développaient plus d'autisme,
ils ont développé plus de maladies métaboliques
et ils ont développé plus de maladies auto-immunes.
Et on a fait une carte de la méthylation
et à nouveau, vous pouvez voir les gènes verts devenir rouges avec le stress.
Les gènes rouges devenir verts avec l'augmentation du stress,
un réarrangement complet du génome en réponse au stress.
Donc si nous pouvons programmer nos gènes,
si nous ne sommes pas de simples esclaves de l'historique de nos gènes,
mais que nous pouvons les programmer, pouvons-nous les déprogrammer ?
Car les conséquences de l'épigénétique peuvent être des maladies comme le cancer,
des maladies métaboliques
et des maladies mentales.
Parlons de l'addiction à la cocaïne.
L'addiction à la cocaïne est une situation terrible,
qui peut mener à la mort, et à la perte de vies humaines.
On se demande
si on peut reprogrammer le cerveau dépendant
pour rendre l'animal non dépendant à nouveau.
On a utilisé des modèles d'addiction à la cocaïne
qui récapitulent ce qu'il se passe chez les humains.
Chez les humains, vous êtes au lycée,
des amis vous proposent de la cocaïne,
vous prenez de la cocaïne, rien ne se passe.
Des mois passent, quelque chose vous rappelle la première fois,
un dealer vous donne de la cocaïne
et vous devenez accro et votre vie a changé.
Avec les rats, on fait la même chose.
Mon collègue, Gal Yadid,
entraîne les animaux à s'habituer à la cocaïne,
puis pendant un mois, plus de cocaïne.
On leur rappelle alors la première fois qu'ils ont vu de la cocaïne
par un signal, les couleurs de la cage quand ils ont vu de la cocaïne,
et ils deviennent fous.
Ils appuieront sur le bouton pour avoir de la cocaïne
jusqu'à en mourir.
On a déduit que la différence entre ces animaux
est que pendant la période où rien ne se passe,
où il n'y a pas de cocaïne,
leur épigénome est réarrangé.
Leurs gènes sont marqués différemment
et quand le signal a lieu, leur génome est prêt
à développer le phénotype dépendant.
On a donné à ces animaux des médicaments qui augmentent la méthylation de leur ADN,
c'étaient les marqueurs épigénétiques à observer,
ou diminuent les marqueurs épigénétiques.
Et on a trouvé qu'en augmentant la méthylation,
ces animaux deviennent encore plus fous.
Ils deviennent encore plus accros à la cocaïne.
Mais si on diminue la méthylation de l'ADN,
l'animal n'est plus dépendant.
On l'a reprogrammé.
Et la différence fondamentale entre les médicaments épigénétiques
et les autres,
c'est qu'avec les médicaments épigénétiques,
on supprime les signes de l'expérience
et une fois supprimés,
ils ne reviendront pas à moins d'en refaire l'expérience.
L'animal est à présent reprogrammé.
Quand on s'intéresse aux animaux 30 ou 60 jours plus tard,
ce qui représente plusieurs années de vie humaine,
ils n'étaient toujours pas accros, grâce à un seul traitement épigénétique.
Qu'a-t-on appris sur l'ADN ?
L'ADN n'est pas seulement une séquence de lettres,
ce n'est pas qu'un script.
L'ADN est un film dynamique.
Nos expériences s'intègrent à ce film, qui est interactif.
C'est comme regarder le film de votre vie, par l'ADN,
avec une télécommande.
Vous pouvez enlever ou ajouter un acteur.
Malgré la nature déterministe de la génétique,
nous avons le contrôle sur l'aspect de nos gènes
et c'est un message très optimiste,
du fait de la capacité à regarder certaines maladies mortelles
comme le cancer ou les maladies mentales,
avec cette nouvelle approche,
de les regarder comme de mauvaises adaptations.
Et si on peut intervenir épigénétiquement,
inverser le film en retirant un acteur
et en mettant en place une nouvelle histoire.
Ce que je vous ai dit aujourd'hui,
c'est que notre ADN est la combinaison de deux composés,
de deux niveaux d'informations.
Un niveau d'informations est vieux,
il a évolué depuis des millions d'années d'évolution,
il est fixe et très dur à modifier.
L'autre niveau d'informations est le niveau épigénétique,
qui est ouvert et dynamique
et met en place une histoire qui est interactive,
qui nous permet de contrôler, de manière plus large, notre destin,
d'aider le destin de nos enfants
et avec un peu de chance de vaincre la maladie
et les défis de santé majeurs
qui ont rongé l'espèce humaine depuis longtemps.
Même si nous sommes déterminés
par nos gènes,
nous avons un degré de liberté
qui peut transformer notre vie en une vie de responsabilité.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)